and a classic car plate registration
changes meant many drivers really
frustrated about what to do especially
if your car needs repairs and you can't
pass a smog test Mary Jimbo yes I has
more repair Pro
helping those with vintage cars get back
on the road
starting this year a smog test will be
required for classic car registration
but what do you do if your car doesn't
pass a smog test then you need to make
repairs on your vehicle the intent of
the classic vehicle place was never to
enable people to avoid a smog check it's
about clean error Kevin Malone the
public information officer for the
Nevada Department of Motor Vehicles says
it all comes down to these requirements
beginning on January 1st we have a new
law that went into effect where you
either have to have classic vehicle
insurance on your car or you have to get
a different plate style and get a small
check if required but if you can't
afford repairs Clark County is rolling
out an assistance program under the smog
free Clark County option owners of model
year vehicles from 1968 to 1995 may
receive up to 975 dollars in emissions
related repairs so how does it work
you'll need to see if you fit the
eligibility requirements before applying
online this includes providing vehicle
registration your ID and the failed smog
certificate once you're approved you can
take your car out for repairs where one
of the authorized shops that are able to
do so were considered a 2G station and
we do emissions related repairs to help
those Vehicles get back on the road and
be emissions compliant smog Hut owner
Jessica wise says this financial option
will help many struggling with these new
regulations I think people are a little
thrown back by the assistance program
they don't really believe that it's true
and happening we've had some people that
were upset to have to get rid of their
classic vehicle plates